et de nous projeter vers l'avenir et
enfin et peut-être surtout l'objectif de
cette visite est évidemment de faire un
point d'étape sur la situation politique
ma position est toujours la même c'est
celle de l'exigence sans ingérence j'ai
vu qu'un processus s'était enclenchée
ces dernières heures qui a permis de
faire émerger une figure en tant que
premier ministre il ne m'appartient
aucunement ni de l'approuver de
l'adouber c'est la souveraineté
libanaise qui est ici en jeu mais de
m'assurer que c'est bien un gouvernement
de mission qui sera formé au plus vite
pour mettre en oeuvre les réformes que
nous connaissons au service des
libanaises et des libanais réforme des
marchés publics de lutte contre la
corruption pour la justice pour la
réforme de l'énergie de l'électricité
pour une meilleure gestion du port pour
une aussi meilleure gestion de la banque
centrale et du système bancaire
autant de réformes indispensables sur
lesquels de mon côté je me suis engagé à
ce que si elles sont prises par le plus
vite possible ce gouvernement de mission
la communauté internationale est
évidemment en premier chef la france
puisse s'engager pour être en soutien du
liban et du peuple libanais voilà les
trois objets de cette visite
au delà du fait que je tenais bien
évidemment à tenir la promesse mais
c'est août dernier voilà mesdames et
messieurs merci beaucoup
merci à toutes et tous et courage merci
[Musique]
exigence sans ingérence ce sont les
premiers mots d' emmanuel macron qui
vient tout juste d'arriver donc à
l'aéroport de beyrouth pour une visite
diplomatique de 24 heures une visite
pour tenter de résoudre une crise
politique profonde pour célébrer
également le premier centenaire de la
programme proclamation du grand liban je
vous propose d'écouter claude
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales
il nous explique en détail les enjeux de
cette venue du président français
cette promesse et cette confirmation de
sa venue a déjà eu un effet nous venons
d'en parler avec la nomination de ce
premier ministre réformateur réformateur
entre guillemets pour le moment et il va
consulter toutes les forces politiques
après s'être entretenu avec le président
de la république monsieur michel
laâyoune et aussi avec bien sûr le
président du parlement qui est président
du parlement depuis 28 ans monsieur
nabih berry et donc il va effectivement
à nouveau leur dire c'est à vous que le
meut l'avenir du liban appartient il
faut que vous créer les conditions d'une
réforme de réformes structurelles au
liban sinon personne ne fera crédit à ce
pays et ne l'aidera à se redresser et il
s'entretiendra aussi avec la population
comme il l'a fait il ya un peu plus de
trois semaines
il y avait cette scène tout à fait
étonnante où il été pris à partie par
une jeune femme libanaise qui lui dit
oui vous voulez vous parler et puis
après vous passerai à autre chose il a
dit non je reviendrai le 1er septembre
et vous verrez que nous nous allons nous
allons progresser alors peut-être la
retrouvera tive en tout cas il
retrouvera d'autres personnages de la
société civile qui lui demanderont
quelle est la prochaine étape est la
visite du président emmanuel macron au
liban nous y reviendrons plus en détail
dans un maintenant un peu moins de 10
minutes pour notre prochain point
complet sur l'actualité a tout de suite
sur rt france
[Musique]